meet taka - Marqui Anouk actin persona 5
royal who helps solve a huge problem
from the base game keeping your SP
topped up for the uninitiated SP
basically functions as mana but it won't
regenerate until you leave the meta bus
so topping it up with items or anything
else is absolutely essential we're about
60 hours into persona 5 royal and have
found that there are actually several
new ways to gain a spate there are will
seeds to be found in palaces the
replenished small amounts of SP and a
stolen the new location kitchy gog which
sells SP replenishing katsu carry but
Marquis entire confidant Ark is
dedicated to getting you more of the
vital resource as well as offering up
some other super helpful abilities
Marquis rocks up at the school after the
main midterm exams which take place once
you've finished the first palace and the
sujin phantom thieves find themselves
somewhat reluctantly enlisted in
attending counseling sessions with them
mechanics and SP boosting elements aside
margie offers up a fascinating new
window to explore psychology and
philosophy in persona 5 and sometimes
provides some truly genuine and
thought-provoking takes on mental health
he's characterised as a handsome dork
with a penchant for rambling but he does
regularly provide snacks when you attend
his sessions which can be used in the
meta verse to cure things like fear and
despair so that's handy
he's extremely friendly and is
particularly concerned with trying to
heal the heart and address psychological
wounds in the same way one would a
physical wound of course were only
halfway through his confidant Ark sir no
doubt there's plenty more to his
personality and story to be uncovered
later at the conclusion of each of
joker's sessions with him you get 5
extra s PT or maximum stat that may not
sound like a lot but it's worth
remembering that five extra SP can get
you through one more battle so stopping
by is well worth your time for the
combat side of the game as well as the
narrative alongside those benefits are
marquees excellent confidant abilities
his Arcana is the counselor yeah look
they were running really low on actual
major arcana ranking him up to level 2
gets you the detox X ability which gives
Joker a chance to immediately remove a
status ailment at rank 3 you'll get flow
which lets you begin battles with both
the charged and concentrated effects
basically turning
into a wrecking ball for the fight then
at rank five you gain mindfulness an
ability that provides a chance to
recover SP when Joker's SP is low this
can be an absolute godsend in a tricky
dungeon you're trying to knock over in
one visit we're currently around the
August point of the game where there
appears to be a soft cap on ranking
Marquis confidante but there are five
more levels yet to come and given he's
already damn useful and quite frankly an
absolute delight to hang out with we're
keen to see more of his mechanical perks
and character arc unraveled throughout
the course of the game if you're keen to
see more check out our gameplay video
where you can see the other new
character Kasumi in action and Michael's
overall impressions from the first 50
hours of Royal
you